how do you keep a conversation going
with
a stranger in this video uh i'm actually
this is doesn't really count as a
stranger so we're gonna set
mr buster
down and i'm actually going to stephen
doesn't know this yet
but stephen my film master i'm going to
ask him a question and we're going to
live demonstrate how to keep a
conversation
going with a stranger i'm chad
littlefield co-author of ask powerful
questions create conversations that
matter and in this video
i hope to show you how to do just that
let's get into it
so for this video i'm going to ask
steven a question and we're going to
have a little mini conversation
and you're a part of this conversation
so you're kind of the observer in this
and i'm going to show you one of the
techniques that we talk about one of my
actually my favorite techniques that we
talk about
um in the book so let me pull up my we
connect cards
and ask steven steven what has been one
of your favorite moments
in life wow um one of my favorite
moments in life
was i actually snuck into disney world
because i was on a band trip
and i forgot my pass and i just snuck in
behind somebody
in like one of those turnstiles so whoa
what's one of your favorite memories
about the person you were with when you
did that my favorite moment about the
person i was with there was that they uh
they were kind of in on it with me and i
was able to sort of just you know get
really small and like go right behind
them and we kind of shared that
you know heist moment that makes sense
cool
so listen to what stephen just shared
from that
little response what did we learn about
steven
now you couldn't see him i was seeing
his face glowing as he's remembering
sneaking behind the lines in disney
but we learned that steven's been to
disney we learned that he was with
somebody when he went to disney
based on the face as he was answering
that we learned
that i think he likes bending the rules
a little bit
perhaps right and we can keep going the
further that we go
answering the question what did we learn
about steven based on that response or
for you
what did you learn about whoever you're
talking to that's probably the more
relevant
conversation to be having here if you're
trying to unpack how to keep a
conversation going with a stranger
right in your own context one of the
best ways is to ask
what did you learn about that person
from what they said so even if they
spoke for five seconds or five minutes
what did you learn about that person
because every item that i learned about
stephen
i could turn into another question and
it would spin off into another
tree of conversation so i learned that
he went to disney and so i could ask
stephen when did you go to disney world
this was uh on a 11th grade band trip
so that would have been 2011. so now
he's just feeding me information right
so now he's in band he's
right so and we didn't stage this um
but you can see how quickly that
conversation actually becomes
exponential
and so when you think about how to keep
a conversation going with a stranger
when you ask how are you or where are
you from or what do you do
you get really stock responses even with
though those stock responses
you learn things about who they are as a
person and when you turn each of those
items into a question
it leaves you with genuinely unlimited
possibilities or directions on where you
could potentially take
that conversation disclaimer as i'm
sitting here recording a video about how
to keep a conversation going with a
stranger
sometimes the best way to keep a
conversation going with a stranger is to
not
to just not keep the conversation going
right so i don't know why you landed on
this video exactly i don't know
what it is that drew you to want to
unpack how to keep a conversation with
going with a stranger i'm assuming
that it's because maybe you start a
conversation and it ends with like
so right and that whatever that awkward
uh thing is you want to avoid that
now sometimes you bump into a
conversation you have a quick
conversation like you don't need to
continue every conversation and turn it
into this big
deep dive into the life of that person
and it's just important to know that so
that we don't trap people in
conversations that they don't want to be
in because conversations
are not just for you you do learn lots
of really cool stuff
through them but they're not just for
you and if you treat them like that
that's super selfish
and it's treating the other person as an
object and i disapprove
cool if you like that i got a really
cool deck of cards it'll keep you
uh talking with strangers for years and
years and years on end
also wrote a book about how to make
conversations that matter you can check
out the links in the description
have an awesome day
[Music]
you